so
the the mask has been created really to
help support our business during coffee
time
the owner of the mask today has
commissioned the mask about
um nine months now or how many months
have passed
so whenever the the situation started
and
we have decided to do something
unusual and something different so
that's how this was born he's a
art collector and he really believes
that within a couple of years
this is going to become a big deal once
all this will be behind us
um the the reason why he commissioned it
it's because we have 120 people
at the factory in israel and when we had
no more sales so we were worried that we
have to let everybody go so he said you
know what i'm gonna try to do something
to help you why don't you make me a mask
and that's how all this was born
we just opened this store in palm beach
we have a lot of friends and a lot of
followers
here on the island and around the area
of florida so we decided to
to put it here for everyone to be able
to come see it and enjoy it and touch it
and feel it
people are curious so it's actually
did quite good for us so we had a lot of
people coming in
and and it did his job so
that's why he's here for people to enjoy
it and to
to get to see it before he's going to be
wearing it probably for the new year
party
most people have read about it already
and they kind of know
the the story behind it so
it's i guess it was an amazing feedback
because
they said you know it's such a great
thing that this person even if
it has you know all this money he did
decide to do
something with it that it's not only
giving it away to a charity which i
don't say it's not good but
the fact that allow all of us to keep
our jobs and work
so that's you know we have a saying in
in hebrew you give a man a fish
or you teach him how to fish so
basically that's what he did he
supported this
side of our philanthropic part of the
business so that's why
people that come in know and understand
this and they're very grateful
and the design of it it's also something
that was very intriguing to them how can
you put this on your face can you wear
it can you take the filter out so we
actually had a couple of approaches
would you do this again
can i you know have my own one so yeah
it was pretty
pretty good
you would wear it at a special event
where you want to
attract attention somehow i guess or
maybe not even attract attention but be
different
and i think the main idea of the mask is
really
becoming a very hopefully in the future
important art piece so more than
anything
the the meaning it's to become
hopefully one day a successful
art piece in a you know in one of the
world's collections so
that's the goal for for the person that
bought it
you